he's an American businessman investor
television personality and
philanthropist he's the owner of the
NBA's Dallas Mavericks and Landmark
Theaters he has an estimated net worth
of three billion u.s. dollars
he is Mark Cuban and here I stopped our
rules for success you know personally I
think every time is a perfect time to
start a business there's no bad times if
you do the work if you do the
preparation you'll know when it's time
and it doesn't mean that it won't be a
little bit scary but you know it's
you'll know and you don't have to quit
the daytime job if you don't feel that
all that comfortable and you can give it
a run at night but whatever works for
you now with the internet um you've got
all the choices in the world and you can
just go out there do your own thing and
and you know set up a business part-time
the passion I've always had for business
and being an entrepreneur the trend that
transfers into the Mavs I've always been
passionate some people thought you know
it's a it's more OCD than anything else
which i think is a great trait for an
entrepreneur um when I you know I
mentioned the stamp business I would
stay up til 3:00 4:00 in the morning
even though I had to get up and go to
school and read Lin stamp news and Scots
stamp journals and have them all
memorized and and use that to give
myself an edge um even when I was in
college I'd be in live in the library
reading business books and just looking
for business biographies and just
reading all I could about business um
when I had Micro solutions and you know
I started with no money
you know I pull all-nighters in in front
of borrowed computers teaching myself
software and and how to program it just
to go after it I mean the thing about
being an entrepreneur is this is just
all to you you know a lot of people like
to make excuses I don't have connections
I don't have money I don't have this but
you know if you find something that you
like to do or love to do be great at it
and see if you can turn it into a
business and worst case you're going to
have fun doing what it is you love to do
in best case you can turn it into a
business I I'm just I'm big on excuses I
just think if you really
everybody has an opportunity to go forth
they just got to do it one of the things
that companies do or startups do they
come up with an idea they'll google it
and if they don't see it in the first
two pages they think it's original
you've got to go back right because over
the past 15 years there's so many
different businesses that have tried and
failed you have to go back and find
those and learn from those so you've got
to understand all the implications and
you have to learn from history and so
the best advice I can give you on a
video before talking to you or emailing
with you is that you've got to find out
the history of people who have tried
your idea because there's a 99.99999%
chance that your idea has been tried
before that's not a good reason not to
start it because you might be able to
outperform them but you better learn
from the history of your idea um because
you know what they say about people who
don't learn from history I've always
just really enjoyed just the competition
of business I think you know in the
sports business I'll talk to our players
and it'll be like well you guys can
people forty eight minutes and you
practice a couple hours and you work on
your game independently a couple hours
but the ultimate sport is business
because you have to compete with
everybody and you have to do a 24 by 7
by 365 days a year forever and there's
always somebody out there trying to kick
your butt there's always somebody who
looks at your business and says I can do
that better I have a better idea and
you're you have to compete with that
person and all the while you have to
make your customers happy your employees
happy it's it's the competitive side of
me that in any entrepreneur that I think
that that has to drive you and and I
think that carries over into the
Mavericks I want to win and I want to
compete
99% of small businesses you can start
with next to no capital it's more about
effort you know small businesses don't
fail for lack of capital they fail for
lack of brains they fail for lack of
effort
most people just aren't willing to put
in the time to work smart I mean they
they go for it in a lot of cases but
they just don't recognize how much works
involved and in
and if you do the preparation if you
know if you start a business you better
know your your industry and your company
better than anyone in the whole wide
world because you're competing and to
think that whoever it is you're
competing with is just going to let you
come in and take their business
obviously that's naive and I think most
people don't recognize that if you're
going to compete with me and one of my
businesses you better realize that I'm
working 24 hours a day to kick your ass
one of the big things that all startups
do is they lie to themselves over and
over and over mines faster mine's
cheaper mine's better mines this mines
that no it's not and the reason it's not
is because whoever it is you're
competing with it's not like they're
ignoring you it's not like oh my
goodness this guy just started on
Shopify in the startup competition he's
doing a million dollars this year what
was me I might as well close up the
doors what are they doing I'm gonna copy
what they're doing and now you've got to
stay ahead and so you know you've got to
be very careful as an entrepreneur to be
brutally honest with yourself and those
are some of the things that you'll hear
from me as a mentor that you know know
what you know know what you don't know
but you've got to know your business
better than anybody I think the most
important is knowing your strengths and
weaknesses and knowing what you enjoy
doing you know if you look at it as a
job you've already lost it's not going
to be your passion and you're going to
count the hours if you look at it as
something you love to do um and then you
know what your strengths are then you
can leverage those strengths in your
business and in helping others and once
you recognize your weaknesses then you
can work with people that compliment you
I mean every one of my businesses I've
had a partner who's very anal Martin
Woodall Todd Wagner I incredibly anal
people perfectionist because I'm a slob
you know I'm a big-picture think about
what's around the corner
how's technology going to change things
how can I change you know this industry
and you know making sure that there's
somebody there to make to dot the i's
cross the t's and keep me in the
baselines Elm and you know recognizing
my weaknesses is just as important as
recognizing my strengths in my core
competencies and and you know having a
passion to do you've got to be
differentiated and unique you've got to
know what your core competency is and be
great at it I think what people fail to
realize is that there's there's got to
be a defining feature of your company
and you've got to be the best in the
world of that whatever industry you're
in if you're if you don't know more
about it than anybody else in the world
whoever those other people out there
know more go to kick your ass I had a
job out of college working for a bank
for a short period of time Mellon Bank
and I am decided to well first it might
have been ink magazine this is way back
when but there was an article about
using changing something in how you
deduct social how you save Social
Security from employees paychecks and
literally hadn't been working there for
three weeks and so I sent it to the CEO
of Mellon Bank hey I thought you might
be interested is literally some guy he
never heard of and I got an OPEX said
thank you nothing okay he looked my
whole job my whole motive in taking a
job working for somebody was to help
them become more profitable that's the
way I always looked at it and then I
started a rookies Club where I reached
out to some executives and all the
people who had started at the same time
at Mellon Bank we don't go out and get a
drink and we'd get this executive start
and I didn't like run it through my boss
or anything and so my boss at the time
calls me in and said you're doing this
is I said yeah I think he's gonna say
great
it's just her screaming at me and
Raymond Meade how could you do this you
go everything through me you work for me
yeah so I knew I wasn't destined there
and then left and I went down to UM
ended up down in Dallas and got a job
working for a company called your
business software and we were we sold
software and I didn't know anything
about software I took one computer class
at Indiana and kind of cheated to pass
but not that I condone that but
and so I had a customer and I thought
might stay up all night teach reading I
think you know computers were new and
technology was new this technology was
new so no way had a head start on me
because it was changing so rapidly like
it is today that if I just put in the
time I can learn as much as anybody else
and so I taught myself I'd stay up late
reading software manuals umm taught
myself different little simple
programming languages and kept on
getting bigger and bigger and better and
better but it was at a retail store and
one of my responsibilities was to come
in
sweep the floor wipe down the windows
and open the store and I had a customer
who wanted me to come out there and
close the deal and it was a fifteen
thousand dollar deal fifteen hundred
dollar commission to me told my boss he
said no you need to be there to open the
store and I made the executive decision
that I was going to go get the check
because you know I was living six guys
in a three-bedroom apartment sleeping on
the floor and this check meant I could
like not use the same holiday in towels
with holes in them that I'd stolen you
know um
but anyway so I went and picked up the
check thank you when I came back and
gave the check to my boss all would be
forgiven and you know the sales cures
all fired me fired me and so those
back-to-back experiences confirmed what
I already knew
that that I was a shitty-ass employee
and then I better start my rings thank
you guys so much for watching now this
video was made because Jose Burgos asked
Evan to on YouTube if you have a famous
entrepreneur that you really want Evan
to make a video of leave it in the
comment below I'd also love to know
which of Mark Cuban's top 10 rules had
the biggest impact on you leave it in
the comments and we're going to join in
the discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and we'll
see you soon